it's time to come together wordsmiths
the word we'll go through in this video
is
collective
Collective it's an
adjective it means something done
together by everyone in a group like we
made a collective decision that se slugs
should be our mascot we did it together
right this word comes from Latin roots
the co-art means with or together like
cohabitate to to live together or
cooperate to work together you might
also see it as con or Comm the Le part
comes from leg which is Latin for to
pick or to gather it's also Latin for to
read but that's another story so
gathered together that's what it means
to collect something right collect
gathered together and this last part Ive
if that's what makes it an adjective a
describing word it means tending to so
therefore something that's Collective
tends to stick together right gathers
things together does things as a group
so using these three elements what other
similar words can you come up with Co or
con um Le or if I'll put on some music
meet me back here in 10
[Music]
seconds okay here's what I came up with
using con I have conduct to guide like a
train conductor or an Orchestra
conductor con together duct uh to lead
you're leading an orchestra together
you're keeping everyone on the train
together using Le I got elect right to
to vote for someone to pick them using
if I got impressive an adjective that
describes something as worthy or
memorable something that might impress
us
right let's use collective in a
sentence because its members loved
arguing The Debate Club struggled to
make Collective decisions right they
couldn't even decide what to order for
dinner as a group well take out menu in
the center you can also use Collective
as a noun although that's a little bit
less common it's it's another way to say
group think of like a a farmers
Collective or a a yarn Collective right
it's it's a group of people that have
come together to accomplish something
together we fly wordsmiths what we do we
do collectively and together I think we
can learn anything David out